in this video i'm going to share with
you my five solar passive design tips
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas i'm a registered architect here
in western australia and today we're
starting the discussion with orientation
of your main living spaces first of all
if you're living in the northern
hemisphere compared to the southern
hemisphere they're going to be
completely opposite so throughout this
video i'm going to be using the southern
hemisphere you want to make sure that
all of your living spaces your kitchen
dining your kitchen is based in the
northern side of the block so it can get
the maximum solar orientation from that
sun throughout the day you want to then
bring your sleeping quarters to the rear
of the property being the south or the
north if you're in the northern
hemisphere traditionally speaking people
are more comfortable sleeping in the
cooler environment of the home hence why
you push the sleeping quarters to the
back or the south of the property next
you want to focus on thermal mass and
you want to be very strategic where you
locate your thermal mass in the property
as an example your concrete slab could
be considered your main area of thermal
mass or it could be something like a
rammed earth wall anything that
basically has a high quality of mass
it's quite obvious what has mass and
what doesn't have mass if it's heavy it
has mass if it's light it doesn't if you
only have one primary thermal mass wall
in your home that's going to radiate
heat throughout that entire space then
you want to locate that as close to your
living area windows as possible because
that sunlight is going to penetrate
through those windows hit that thermal
mass wall absorb all that heat and then
radiate it back out throughout the day
if for example you live in an extremely
cold climate that doesn't get much sun
at all you can locate that thermal mass
wall or thermal mass area on the floor
next to a heating source so if you have
a good fire log heater gas heater
whatever kind of heating source you want
to locate that thermal mass wall as
close to it as possible to be able to
then basically absorb that heat and
distribute it when that fire is no
longer active now i know everybody loves
their windows everybody loves looking at
the view however you really want to be
able to minimize your glazing throughout
the house to make sure that you're not
releasing too much of the actual heat so
you want to focus on the northern wall
again for the southern hemisphere and
aim to have about 15 to 25 of the floor
area as actual glazing you can go over
that percentage obviously that is just a
guide and you want to be using them
specifically for your project however if
you do go over that percentage it tends
to traditionally make the build cost a
little bit more expensive as that number
progressively gets higher over 25 going
back one step and if you're living in
one of those climate zones that is
extremely cold and you cannot heat or
cool your house effectively throughout
the year you might want to consider an
airlock so traditionally speaking an
airlock is going to be a small little
confined space completely sealed off so
that once you walk in the cold air or
the hot air from the outside doesn't
immediately distribute throughout your
entire space last but not least this is
critical to any house you live in it can
be something that you action today it
can be something that you plan for
tomorrow or it can be something that you
simply remember for the rest of your
life the main point here is that air
leaks will destroy any good solar
passive design and that's all from me
thanks so much for watching i'll see you
next time